the human experience is defined by a
thirst an unquenchable thirst of burning
in the belly a thirst for meaning do we
mean when we talk about me we have an
autobiographical mind we live by a
mythology we see our lives in the
context of a symbolic systems of
identifications and affiliations and
definitions we are a story and when we
talk about meaning we want the story to
have a purpose to have a plot to have
consummation consecration to overcome
odds to slay dragon to learn from the
obstacles that we slay to come back
somebody who can then teach and bestow
the knowledge to somebody else I mean we
are hungry for signification we are
starved for offense that we matter sense
that it's for something sense that in
the end
ashes to ashes dust to dust has some
semblance of something-something behind
it this is what we mean by meaning the
human condition is a bit absurd we are a
miracle we are the miracle the miracle
divinity in flesh and blood
divinity incarnate and yet in the end we
are food for worms we wither away we
witness our own withering this is
horrendous this is a death sentence yet
we're here we're alive what might we do
what can we do what we will move therein
lies the challenge therein lies search
the search the novel the moviegoers said
is what anyone would undertake if you
were not stuck in the everydayness of
his or her own life to be aware of the
possibility of the search is to beyond
to someone
not to be on just to be in despair is to
be the state of paralyzing anxiety so
you know go out there take the journey
go on the search
be a seeker
you